الى برلين حيث اجرى المستشار الالماني
مباحثات مع رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد
شياع السوداني في مقر المستشاريه وبحث
المسؤولان سبل تطوير العلاقات بين البلدين
وقال المستشار الالماني من العراق قد يكون
شريكا مهما لبلاده في مجال الطاقه من
برلين نظم الينا مراسل الجزيره عيسى
الطيبي عيسى يبدو ان الطاقه حاضره بقوه في
هذه القمه بين المانيا والعراق
لرئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد شهير السوداني
العلامه الابرز اليوم في هذه القمه
العراقيه الالمانيه هي مساله الطاقه بدا
من من من التوقيع على الاتفاقيه بين
الحكومه الالمانيه عفو الحكومه العراقيه
وشركه السيموس لبناء مشاريع جديده وضخمه
في العراق في مجال الطاقه الكهربائيه
وايضا تجديد همم
تجديد المؤسسات الكهربائيه الموجوده اصلا
هناك الامر الثاني هو ما طرحه ومعرضه
الحكومه العراقيه كما قال رئيس الوزراء
العراقي وهو مساله الغاز تحديدا قال بانه
هناك ثلاث انواع من في مجالات الطاقه
عرضناها على المانيا اولها الغاز المصاحب
وهو ذلك الغاز الذي يتم حرقه اثناء
استخراج البترول والامر الثاني هو الغاز
الطبيعي
بان لدى العراق اكتشافات في مجال الغاز
الطبيعي وبانها تحتاج لخبره المانيا في
استخراجه والامر الثالث هو في مجال
البتروكيمياويات وبالتالي يريد كما قال
نريد من الشركات الالمانيه من الحكومه
الالمانيه ان تعطينا عروضا في هذا المجال
لان العلاقه واحد من اهم الدول المصدره
والتي تمتلك احتياطات ضخمه من البترول
الامر الاخر وهو تحديدا ملفات مرتبطه
بالحاله العراقيه الالمانيه تحدث عن
المستشار عن المساله عن ملف اللاجئين
والمهاجرين العراقيين وكيفيه العمل مع
الحكومه الحاليه لعودته من العراق
للتذكير بان رئيس وزراء العراق يضم وفدا
يضم وزيره الهجره وزير الخارجيه ووزيره
الكهرباء ايضا تحدث المستشار عن ما سماه
وجود اكثر من مليون واا 200,000 من ضحايا
الحروف العراق يتصدرهم اليزيديين وقال بان
هذا الملف
تحدث معه مع الحكومه الالمانيه تحدث ايضا
عن مساله همم دور العراق في الوساطه في
المنطقه رئيس وزراء العراق ايضا فتح ملفات
اخرى وهي ملف مطالبه المانيا باسترداد
الاموال المنهوبه
والاسماء التي من الشخصيات التي هربت الى
الالمانيا ايضا طالب المانيا باسترداد
الاثار وكان واضحا بان هذه المطالبات قد
تم بحثها ايضا امس لان رئيس الوزراء
العراقي قال باننا بحثنا هذا الامر وقانا
عقودا يوم امس في برلين ايضا تم الحديث عن
مساله هل سيكون العراق بديلا لبعض البلدان
وخصوصا اننا المانيا الان تتجه البترول من
كازاخستان قال المستشار الالماني انه يريد
تنويع مصادر الطاقه بان المانيا تريد ان
يكون العراق وتتمنى ان يكون العراق احد
مصادرها في مجاري من مجال البترول
تحدث ايضا المستشار عن المنظومه القانونيه
عندما طلب منه رئيس الوزراء العراقي بان
تاتي الشركات الالمانيه والسياح الالماني
للعراق قال ان العراق ايضا مطالب بمنظومه
قانونيه واضحه تحمي مصالح المستثمرين تحمي
العلاقه بين المستثمرين والشركات
الالمانيه
والجانب العراقي الذي تغير الملفات وتتغير
الحكومات بتغير القوانين لذلك كانت هذه
الزياره الطاقه زياره استثمار عنوانها
الابرز وكما قال المستشار الالماني بان
حكومه الشياع تريد ان تركز على الاصلاح
الاقتصادي على النمو الاقتصادي في العراق